what I was doing was that trying on my
contacts and experiences in Afghanistan
and in Pakistan in the 1980s I was
trying to reach Taliban leaders in the
1980s I went through the tribal areas
hiked up into Afghanistan lived in the
mountains of Afghanistan and down in the
deserts of Kandahar with the Mujahideen
then America's close allies against the
war fighting the Soviet Union I was a
newspaper reporter for The New York
Times and my over a period of time I got
to know what we call Pashtunwali which
would be called the tribal code of the
Pashtuns pashtoon being the principal
ethnic group in Afghanistan and across
the border in Pakistan the Taliban or
Pashtuns because I knew these men from
before when the United States he when
the United States invaded Afghanistan
and october two thousand one a great
many of the former Mujahideen went to
work with the United States and NATO
they joined the West it became part of
the government they had businesses other
men I knew from the 1980s went up into
the mountains and began to lead the
fight against the US I knew this network
for having been there in the 1980s
having worked with them for over a
period of time I had written a book
about them I understood to a degree the
tribal culture the role of Islam and
where Islam and tribal culture worked
and we're tribal laws took precedence
and were Islam took presidents an
understanding of the language I knew how
to dress how to act how to walk how to
look at a man in a way how to eat how to
wash my hands how to pass almost but not
entirely as a pashtoon so what I was
doing was trying on my contacts heading
out with these with these bodyguards and
this interpreter and this took months to
arrange had already been with the
Taliban four times I'd already crossed
into the tribal areas four times but
this was a trip to go deep into the
tribal areas to perhaps get to the
Taliban leaders and through them to
al-qaeda to find out who the Taliban
really were who is behind the Taliban
and to what degree they are tied to Al
Qaeda and where the al Qaeda leadership
is located
that was my goal that was what I was
trying to do
it's an old comes from Kipling and he
heard it it was came long before him
here Eliza fool who tried to hustle the
East what I was doing for months when I
was traveling along the border off and
on and going with the Taliban and all
the work that I was doing I took my time
I didn't push it I operated by pashtoon
rules Pashtun time I did I I lived
according to their ways as much as I
could I fasted during Ramadan I would
eat in the same way i would take my time
everything I did but was in the way of
the Pashtuns as I remembered it from the
1980s however I became so driven vam
bishan blind to what was going on around
me wasn't fully aware of some of the
intrigue it was circling all around me I
knew about betrayal I'd already been
betrayed once by one Taliban group I did
I have letters of the threatening
letters threatening my life I knew this
others were after me I was living in a
very dark paranoid world completely
separate from the West I didn't register
at the US Embassy I knew I had to avoid
all journalists all afghan-pakistani in
US and NATO military institutions and
intelligence agencies living in this
very dark world trying to move as an
Afghan but my deadline for the book was
approaching I was running out of money
because i had to pay men up and down the
border in order to put this all these
projects together I was running so many
different men that I became anxious
desperate I have to move and when I got
a call from one of my main sources one
of my main contacts a former Mujahideen
later today a prominent member of
parliament who had arranged for me to go
and meet with this prominent Taliban
leader when he told me not to go because
I was desperate and had to move I
ignored him a decision that changed my
life